[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات عواصم في
العالم تعيش على وقع احداث هامه البدايه
من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم والمشهد من
هناك في ختام يوم من المواجهات المسلحه
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف عقب ساعات من
اعلان حاله التاهب الجوي في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه وذوي صفارات الانذار في
المنطقه
والى العاصمه البريطانيه لندن التي تستعد
لمراسم تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث ملكا
للبلاد غدا السبت
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في ختام الاسبوع الثالث للمواجهات في
السودان
تصاعد المعارك رغم تعهدات الهدنه دوي
انفجارات قويه تزامنا مع تحليق طائرات
حربيه وسط الخرطوم وفي محيط القصر الرئاسي
ووزير الخارجيه الكيني يحذر في لقاء مع
الجزيره من تفكك السودان الى جيوب صغيره
وفي التداعيات الانسانيه للمواجهات الامم
المتحده تحذر
19 مليون شخص في السودان قد يعانون سوء
تغذيه حاده خلال الاشهر المقبله
واليونيسيف تقول ان معارك السودان تحصد
اطفالا باعداد كبيره مرعبه وتكشف عن تدمير
اكثر من مليون جرعه لقاح ضد شلل الاطفال
والكاميرا الجزيره ترصد الاوضاع داخل
المستشفيات
وسط توقعات ببدء هجوم الاوكراني مضاد خلال
ساعات او ايام انفجارات تدوي في مقاطعه
سافا جنوب اوكرانيا موسكو تعلن بدء هجوم
للقوات الروسيه في باك موت بدعم من القوات
المحموله جوا وللمره الثانيه خلال يومين
هجوم جديد بالمسيرات في العمق الروسي
بعد اكثر من ثلاث سنوات على انتشار الوباء
منظمه الصحه العالميه تعلن رفع حاله
الانذار القصوى المرتبطه بجائحه كورونا
تحذر من التراخي اتلس 20
وتكشف عن ارقام لوفيات بسبب الفيروس تناهز
20 مليونا هي اعلى ثلاث مرات من تقديرات
رسميه معلنه سابقا
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصائد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم ما اعلنته منظمه
الصحه العالميه من ان كوفي 19 بات الان
تحت سيطره كافيه لكي يتم رفع حاله الانذار
القصوى المرتبطه به وذلك بعد اكثر من ثلاث
سنوات على انتشار هذا الوباء الذي تسبب
بملايين الوفيات باستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
والسؤال يقول ما ابرز ما كشفت عنه جائحه
كورونا النتائج جاءت على النحو التالي 57
بالمئه قالوا ان الجائحه اظهرت هشاشه
الانظمه الصحيه الوطنيه بينما قال عشره
بالمئه ان ازمه فيروس كورونا كشفت غياب
العداله في توزيع اللقاحات اما نحو ثلاثه
33% فاعتبروا ان سوء التنسيق على المستوى
الصحي العالمي هو اهم ما كشفته الجائحه
هذا السؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
كالعاده ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون معنا في الحصاد ايضا
عشيه تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث العاصمه
البريطانيه تستعد لحفل تاريخي لم تشهد له
مثيلا منذ عقود
[موسيقى]
ملفته الحصاد نبداها من السودان والوضع
الميداني هناك فقد افاد مراسلنا ان دويا
انفجارات قويه سمعت تزامنا مع تحليق
طائرات حربيه وسط الخرطوم وفي محيط القصر
الرئاسي اما في محيط القصر الجمهوري فقد
دوت انفجار عنيفه واصوات اسلحه ثقيله في
الاشتباكات كما افاد مراسلنا بسماع دوي
انفجار في منطقه الجريف شرق في الخرطوم
بحري شرق الخرطوم مع استمرار تحليق طائرات
وسماع اصوات مضادات ارضيه في الاثناء قال
الجيش في بيان ان من وصفهم بالمتمردين
هاجموا منطقه الخرطوم بحر العسكريه ومنطقه
العاصمه العسكريه مؤكدا انه صد هذا الهجوم
المشهد الميداني تركز اليوم بشكل اساسي في
العاصمه الخرطوم بمدنها الثلاث تحليق
المكثف للطيران الحربي مع تواصل
الاشتباكات في محيط القصر الجمهوري فيما
قالت قوات الدعم السريع انها تصدت لهجمات
متكرره من الجيش الى الشمال قليلا في
الخرطوم بحري هزه انفجارات وسط المنطقه
وتصاعدت اعمده الدخان في سماء حي الوبورت
الوبورت وقال الجيش ان من وصفهم
بالمتمردين هاجموا منطقه الخرطوم بحر
العسكريه ومنطقه العاصمه العسكريه مؤكدا
انه تمكن من صد الهجوم
وفي الخرطوم بحري كذلك قال الدعم السريع
ان الجيش سن هجمات على مقر للدعم السريع
قرب سلاح المظلات في المنطقه الغربيه من
الخرطوم بحري تحديدا منطقه حله حمد وفي
شان ميدانيا اخر قال الجيش السوداني ان
قوات الدعم السريع اجبرت مهندسين على
تعطيل محطات التحكم للكهرباء والمياه ما
ادى لانقطاعها عن مناطق واسعه بالبلاد
بينما نفت قوات الدعم السريع ذلك وقالت
انها تعمل على استعاده الخدمات مع الفرق
الهندسيه المختصه
ينضم الينا الان مراسل الجزيره هيثم اويت
هيثم كيف هي الاوضاع الان
الاوضاع الان على الاقل في مدينه ام درمان
ان تشهد بعض الهدوء الذي يسيطر على هذه
المدينه التي شهدت في السابق كانت بعض
المواجهات ولكن في الايام القليله الماضيه
ظلت على هذا الحال من الهدوء لم نلحظ اي
اشتباكات او هجمات في هذه المنطقه سوى
تحليق لطائرات تابعه للجيش في سماء
المدينه عاده ما تنفذ اهداف لمناطق اخرى
في الخرطوم البحري او الخرطوم الشرق ما
يدور الان من احداث هو في منطقه شرق النيل
في الخرطوم في الجزء الشرقي من منطقه
النيل هناك اشتباكات عنيفه تدور بين قوات
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في معسكر خوله
الذي تتمركز فيه قوات الدعم السريع وهو
مقر لهذه القوات كان عاده تقوم طيران
الجيش السوداني
ضرب هذه المناطق الطيران الحربي ولكن الان
الجديد في الامر ان هناك اشتباك بري ارضي
اي ان هناك قوه تحركت لهذه المنطقه وعبرت
كبرها المنشيه من اتجاهين وهناك الان
اشتباكات تدور هذه تلك المنطقه وهو التطور
الاحدث في هذه المنطقه منطقه الخرطوم بحري
شرق النيل تحديدا ايضا في وسط الخرطوم
كانت وحتى ساعات المساء القليل الماضيه
كانت هناك اشتباكات تدور في محيط القصر
الرئاسي وكانت تسمع اصوات الاشتباكات بشكل
مكثف في محيط القصر وايضا في منطقه الوسط
الشرق البحري في منطقه حيل وبورات حيث
تصاعدت اعمده الدخان نتيجه لهذه
الاشتباكات المتواصله طبعا هذه الاشتباكات
تم تاتي في وقت ما تزال فيه الهدنه مستمره
الهدنه السابعه في يومها الثاني رغم
التاكيدات والالتزامات من الاطراف بان هذه
الهدنه مرحب بها وان الاطراف تعمل على
تنفيذها ولكن على الارض نشاهد هذه
الهجمات والمواجهات التي لا تزال تسيطر
على المشهد الميداني والذي اكيد له
انعكاسات عديده على المشهد الانساني وايضا
الاقتصادي والصحي ماذا عن جنوب الخرطوم
طاهر المرضي يضعنا في الصوره طهر
نعم في جنوب الخرطوم هنا هدوء يعني حجر في
هذه المنطقه لا نسمع اصوات للاشتباكات عاد
التي حدثت قبل قليل كانت في شرق النيل
كانت هناك بالفعل الاشتباكات عنيفه في هذه
المنطقه بالقرب من مستشفى الشرق النيل
ولكن هنا في جنوب الخرطوم او هنا هدوء
وهذا الهدوء هو هدوء حذر او ان كانت هذه
الهدنه غير متماسكه ولكن هنالك امل بان
تستمر هذه الهدنه وان يصل الطرفان الى وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار ولكن لاحظنا ايضا ان
الاوضاع الانسانيه وتفاقم الازمه
الانسانيه الان بدات في التزايد خاصه
عندما مررنا على بعض الاسواق الشعبيه
وجدنا ان هنالك اسعار غاليه بالنسبه
للسلعه الضروريه خاصه للخبز وبعض متطلبات
الحياه المتعلقه
الماء والكهرباء والانقطاع الذي استمر
لفتره على الرغم من ان هنالك عوده تدريجيه
لهذا التيار ولكن الظروف التي عاشها
المواطن هي ظروف ظروف حرب خاصه وان هنالك
شحف السيوله في الحصول على احتياجاته
وكذلك بعض الصيدليات في انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي تاثرت بعض الادويه المتعلقه
بالمنقذه للحياه المتعلقه بحفظ درجات اقل
بالنسبه للحراره هذا اثر ايضا بشكل كبير
وبالتالي نحن نلاحظ ان المواطنين الان بدو
يتاثرون خاصه وان شحا الوقود ايضا اثر على
حركتهم في جلب اغراضهم من مواقع ربما تكون
بعيده مما كان سكنهم بالاضافه الى ان
الاحياء القريبه من دائره الاشتباكات ما
تزال يعني
تتاثر تاثرا كبيرا وتقشاه من ان تكون
هنالك يكون هنالك ضحايا او مصابين بسبب
الاشتباكات بالاضافه الى ان
ازمه
الوقود اثرت على ايضا على عدد المغادرين
للعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ولكن هنالك
تطلع لان تكون المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه او مبادره لايجاد لها الدور
الفعال في وقت هذا القتال والوصول الى حل
سلمى يسكت هذه البندقيه باعتبار ان هذه
الحرب اذا ما استمرت الى اكثر من هذا ربما
تؤدي الى تاثير كبير فيما يقتص بالاوضاع
الانسانيه والسلع الضروريه على الرغم من
ان بعض الولايات اتخذت او اصدرت او اعلنت
قانون الطوارئ في ست ولايات حفاظا على
السلعه الضروريه وعدم نقلها ونحن نشاهد ان
هنالك سوق سوداء بدات الان تتاجر في
السلعه الضروريه مثل الخبز والوقود وبعض
الجوانب المتعلقه ايضا
بالسيوله خاصه وان المصارف الخرطوم ما
تزال مغلقه والت طبيقات البنكيه متعثره
والمواطن الواجب هذه الصعوبات بطريقه
كبيره شكرا لكم الطاهر من جنوبي الخرطوم
وهيثم من ام درمان
وقد كان وزير الخارجيه الفريد مونتوا قد
قال في مقابله مع الجزيره ان بلاده تشعر
بقلق من احتمال تفكك السودان وتحوله الى
جيوب صغيره واضاف ان بلاده لا تريد
للسودان ان يتحول الى ساحه حرب بالوكاله
ويكون سنه
نحن قلقون بشان عدد من الامور اولا نحن
قلقون من احتمال تفكك السودان لا نريد
للسودان ان يتفكك الى جيوب صغيره فتصبح
الامه السودانيه امه بلا دوله
ثانيا نحن نقلقون بسبب الازمه الانسانيه
في المنطقه
ووفقا لمفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين هناك اكثر من مليون من النازحين
داخل السودان ثالثا حيثما كانت حكومات او
بلدان غير مستقره في هذه القاره لا تمتلك
نظام حكم مستقر وفيها حروب اهليه تتحول
الى ارض خصبها للارهاب ورابعا نحن لا نريد
للسودان ان يتحول الى ساحه حرب بالوكاله
السوداني ضياء الدين بلال اهلا وسهلا بك
واضح ان القلق الاقليمي والدولي يزداد مما
يحصل في السودان هل يمكن ان يؤثر في شيء
نعم هذا هو على قلق تم التعبير عنه من
اليوم الاول ولكن مع تفاقم الازمه
الانسانيه اعتقد ان القلق الاقليمي
والدولي سيزداد ومع تطاول مدى الحرب هنالك
احتمال لتدخل اجنده اخرى عابر الحدود من
اطراف اقليميه واطراف دوليه وقد يصبح
السودان نقطه ارتكاز لصراعات مختلفه
ومتعدده الاخطاب ومتعدده الاوجه فهذه
المخاوف مخاوف الطبيعيه
تبرر لها المعطيات الراحنه الان في
استمرار الصراع وفي التعقيد الاوضاع
الانسانيه عندما يشير الوزير كما كنا
نتابع الى الخوف من حرب الوكاله
ماذا يمكن ان يفهم نعم هو ينظر الى
احتمالات بان تكون هنالك صراعات اقليميه
تنتقل الان هدات الجبهه الليبيه فمن
المحتمل ان يصبح السودان هو المسرح الاخر
لهذا الصراع وكما انه هنالك تقاطعات اخرى
للنفوز السوفيتي في المنطقه والنفوز
الامريكي وهناك تدخلات باشكال مختلفه
فالسودان ارض منخفضه تعبر اليها الاجنده
بسهوله ويسر فبالتالي من الطبيعه ان يكون
هنالك تخوف من ان تتفاعل هذه الاجنده
العابره وان تنتج واقع اخر حرب غير الحرب
التي اشعلت وان تتحور وتتغير طبيعه هذه
الحرب الى حرب اقليميه او حرب متعدده
الاوجه خاصه وان رواه الدعم السريع لها
امتدادات في العمق الافريقي لها امتدادات
في غرب افريقيا
في النيجر في تشاد في اماكن اخرى وتظهر
فيديوهات لهذه المجموعات تتحدث عن ضروره
انتصار حم التيفي في السودان فاعتقد ان
عامل الزمن ليس في مصلحه السودان كوطن
الاولى فربما تتفاقم الازمه الانسانيه
اكثر واكثر وتعبر الاجنده لتشعل الصراع
اكثر واكثر قبل قليل الجيش السوداني قال
انه لم يعني بما معناه لم يستعمل بعد كل
قوته
هل هل يمكن ان نفهم من ذلك بان الايام
المقبله سيكثف
قصف وتحركات اعتقد ان انه اذا لم يتم
الوصول او تفاهم مع الدعم السريع للخروج
من مركز الخرطوم واخلاق المناطق
الاستراتيجيه ربما يضطر الجيش لاستخدام
اسلحه غير الاسلحه التي استخدمت خاصه وان
الان الدعم السريعي يحاول ان يفاقم من
الازمه الانسانيه
بسطرته على المستشفيات اكثر من 12 من
المستشفى تم السيطره عليها واليوم تم
السيطره عليه الامدادات الطبيه التي تغذي
كل السودان بالادويه وهنالك سيطر على
مواقع استراتيجيه مستر الكهرباء ومستر
الغاز
[موسيقى]
نريد ان يمضي اكثر من ذلك ولكن الدعم
السريعي يتوقع يتحدث عن ايقاف
دائم لاطلاق النار لانه يريد ان يحافظ على
ما حقق دون ان يخسر ذلك فهنالك اختلاف في
اجنده ورغبات الاطراف فهذا امر
يتيح مساحه اكبر للحركات للعمليات
العسكريه التي هي ستحدد ما ستؤول اليه
الاوضاع اكثر من
المناقشات والمفاوضات التي تجري اذا كانت
في السعوديه او عبر الايجارات او عبره اي
طرف اخر شكرا جزيلا لك السيد زياد الدين
بلال شكرا
مصدرون بالجيش السوداني للجزيره ان الجيش
ارسل اللواء ابو بكر فقيري وضابطين وسفيرا
الى جده للتفاوض مع وفد من الدعم السريع
واشار المصدر الى ان قبول التفاوض ياتي
استجابه للمبادره الامريكيه السعوديه وشدد
المصدر على ان التفاوض سيكون في القضايا
العسكريه والانسانيه ولا علاقه له باي
قضايا سياسيه
[موسيقى]
وفي التداهيه الانسانيه للشبكات الجاريه
في السودان حذر فرحان حق نائب المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده من ان
استمرار الصراع في السودان سيؤدي الى
زياده عدد من يعانون انعدام الامن الغذائي
بمليونين ونصف المليون ليصل الى 19 مليون
خلال الاشهر المقبله واشرحت الى الحاجه
لتوفير نحو نصف مليار دولار لدعم احتياجات
طالبيه اللجوء في الدول المجاوره للسودان
يتوقع برنامج الاغذيه العالمي ارتفاع عدد
الذين يعانون من انعدام امن الغذائي في
السودان ما بين مليوني شخص ومليونين ونصفه
مما سيرفع العدد الى تسعه عشر مليون شخص
اذا استمر الصراع خلال الاشهر السته
المقبله وكاله اللاجئين اعلنت ان هناك
حاجه الى 445 مليون دولار لدعم تدفق نحو
860 الف لاجئ وعائد من السودان في خمس دول
متضرره من الوضع
الاثناء قال الجيش السوداني ان من سماهم
المتمردين اجبروا مهندسين على تعطيل محطات
التحكم في الكهرباء والمياه ما ادى الى
انقطاعها عن مناطق واسعه بالبلاد وفقا
لبيان الجيش من جانبها قالت قوات الدعم
السريع في بيان لها انها تعمل على استعاده
خدمه الكهرباء في عدد من ولايتي ومدن شرقي
ووسط السودان بمعاونه مهندسين فنيين
واضافت انها تواصل العمل مع فريقا هندسي
كبير لاصلاح الخلل في محطه مياه بحري
مضيفه ان من وصفتهم بالانقلابيين اطلقوا
النار على المحطه للحقول دون وصول الفريق
الهندسي وقالت انها تعمل على ايجاد حلول
للمشكله القائمه
السودانيه ايضا قلم سولونا في مستشفى احمد
قاسم بالخرطوم بحري للجزيره ان المواد
الطبيه الخاصه بمرضى غسل الكلى على وشك
النفاذ بسبب انقطاع الامداد واوضح
المسؤولون الطبيون ان المستشفى يستقبل
يوميا نحو 60 شخصا من مرضى غسل الكلى وهو
ما يفوق طاقته الاستيعابيه واضاف مختصون
طبيون ان خروج مستشفيات عده من الخدمه زاد
من الطلب على المستلزمات الطبيه وشكل ضغطا
كبيرا على الكادر الطبي وقد حذرت
اليونيسيف من ارتفاع عدد الاطفال القتلى
والجرحى في الصراع الدائري في السودان منذ
ثلاثه اسابيع وسط غياب اي افق للحوار بين
المتقاتلين اما المفوضيه الساميه لشؤون
اللاجئين فحثت الدول على ابقاء حدودها
مفتوحه امام الفارين من العنف والسماح لهم
بالوصول دون تمييز
السودان بعد اكثر من 20 يوما من الحرب
المفتوحه على الاسوا البلد يتمزق سياسيا
وامنيا واجتماعيا وشعبه يعيش كارثه
انسانيا كبرى نادرا متوثقها الكاميرات
العنف بلغ مستوى من الخطوره جعل الاجانب
يغادرون والسفارات تغلق ابوابها ومؤسسات
الامم المتحده تعمل عن بعد من دول الجوار
ومنسق المنظمه لحالات الطوارئ مارتن
جريفيث ينتظر منذ ايام موعدا مع قاده
معسكرين المتصارعين يبدو ان انتظاره
لضمانات من اجل ممر امن لمساعدات
الانسانيه سيطول كثيرا لهدن تحترمت ولا
تحذير وصل صداه الى من بيتهم السلاح محنه
المدنيين السودانيين تكبر وتتعاظم مع كل
دقيقه وليس ساعه تغتال فيها فرص عوده
الامان المفقود تفاصيل القطاع الصحي قاسيه
ومخيفه يستغيث مسؤول مستشفى احمد قاسم في
الخرطوم بحري بقرب نفاذ المواد الطبيه
الخاصه بمرضى غسيل الكلى من جهتها حدثت
لجنه اطباء السودان قائمه المرافق
المتضرره من دوامه العنف سبعه عشر مستشفى
تضررت جراء القتال اخلي عشرون قصرا منذ
الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي 60 مستشفى من
اصل 88 في الخرطوم خارج الخدمه الان وتلك
العامله لتقدم كامله خدماتها تحذير اخر من
اليونيسف عن طفوله تغتال في السودان
بالرصاص وبتداعيات حرب اخفقت الامم
المتحده في منع اندلاعها
المنظمه تلقى التقارير تفيد بان 190 طفلا
قتلوا 1700 اخرين اصيبوا بجروح خلال 11
يوما الاولى فقط من القتال الذي بدا في
الخامس عشر من ابريل الواقع سيء من جميع
النواحي
صيغه الاحتمالات معركه تبادل الاتهامات
بين المتقاتلين على الارض لا تعرف سوى
التصعيد قال الجيش السوداني ان قوات الدعم
السريع اجبرت مهندسين على تعطيل التحكم في
المياه والكهرباء نفت القوات الاتهامات
وردت انها تعمل على استعاده الخدمات مع
الفرق الهندسيه دخان الاشتباكات يحجب رؤيه
حقيقه ما يجري ومن يسيطر على ماذا في
الخرطوم ودارفور غير ان الصوره المرعبه
للفارين من البلاد والرحله الشاقه للوصول
الى الحدود وضحه جدا سيكونون اكثر خلال
الفتره المقبله تحذر المفوضيه الساميه
لشؤون اللاجئين
هناك ما يزيد عن 100 الف من السودانيين
وغيرهم من الذين عبروا الى دول الجوار
للحصول على مكان امن مثل جنوب السودان
ومصر وتشاد هناك اعداد تغادر كل يوم
بالتالي تجاوزنا رقم المئه الف وقدرنا انه
اذا تواصل الامر على هذه الحال سيكون هناك
اكثر من 860 الف لاجئ من السودان الى دول
الجوار
من الصعب يحصلوا اعداد النازحين داخل
البلاد ولكنهم ايضا بعشرات الالاف
ويعتمدون على التعاضد الاجتماعي لمواجهه
المحنه واوزار صراع الاخرين على السلطه من
وما الذي اوصل السودان الى كل هذه الالم
المتحاربون ام الداعمون لهم ام المجتمع
الدولي العاجز عن فعل اي شيء ما عدا
الشعور بالقلق مما يجري هناك
[موسيقى]
الان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره ان السلطات
الاوكرانيه اعلنت حاله التاهب الجوي في
العاصمه كافرات الانذار دوت في المنطقه
تزامن هذا ما اعلاني نائب وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تحاول
السيطره على بخموت بالكامل بحلول التاسع
من مايو ايار الحالي وكانت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه قد اعلنت انها بدات هجوما جديدا
بدعم من القوات المحموله جوا للسيطره على
المدينه وان قواتها تواصل التقدم في الجزء
الغربي
واكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تدبير جسر في
منطقه شاسوفيا
تستخدمه القوات الاوكرانيه لارسال
التعزيزات الى المدينه
على محور دونتس تواصل الوحدات الهجوميه شن
عمليات في الجزء الغربي من مدينه باخمت
مدعومه بوحدات القوات المحموله جوا في
مدينه تشاسو فيار تم تدمير جسر حاولت
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه عبره القيام
بتوريد الذخيره ونقل الاحتياطات الى باخمت
لهذا الاتجاه بلغت الخسائر في صفوف الجيش
الاوكراني 300 من العسكريين والمرتزقه
وكان رئيس مجموعه فاجناريا فيروجين قد
اعلن انسحاب مقاتلهم من مدينه باق موت
اعتبارا من العاشر من هذا الشهر بسبب نقص
الذخيره واتهم بريكوجين هيئه الاركان
العامه بعدم ارسال ما يكفي من الذخائر الى
قواته بقصد حرمانها من تحقيق نصر يعجز عنه
الجيش النظامي وفق قوله
اتحدث نيابه عن نفسي وعن مقاتلي فاجا
اخاطب رئيس الاركان العامه ووزير الدفاع
والقائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه والشعب
الروسي بالسادس عشر من مارس عام 2022
عندما لم تسر العمليه العسكريه الخاصه حسب
الخطه طلبت منا المساعده بعد ثلاثه ايام
وصلت وحداتنا من افريقيا مجهزه تجهيزا
كاملا وانضمت الى المعركه على الفور لقد
اعلنا حاله عجز الذخيره كنا نتلقى ثلاثين
في المئه فقط مما نحتاجه لهذا السبب كانت
خسائرنا اعلى بكثير مما كان ينبغي ان تكون
عليه لكننا واصلنا المضي قدما قبل شهر
توقفوا عن تزويدنا بالذخيره ولم نحصل الا
على عشره في المئه كنا بصدد الاستيلاء على
باخمت بحلول التاسع من مايو عام 2023
تزامنا مع يوم النصر عندما راى
البيروقراطيون العسكريون ذلك اوقفوا
امدادات
ابلغوا وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان العامه
والقائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه رسميا ان
رفاق لن يتكبدوا خسائر غير مجديه وغير
مبرره في باخمت دون ذخيره لذلك في العاشر
من مايو عام 2023
سننسحب من بخوت وفي وقت سابق نشر الرئيس
باجنر عبر حسابه في تيليجرام مقطعا مصورا
تظهر فيه وراءه جثث يقول انها لافراد من
قوته سقطوا في معارك بخموت بسبب نقص
الذخيره وهاجم بريكوجين بشكل مباشر وزير
الدفاع سرقه وقائد الاركان
مستخدما سبابا مباشرا في حقهما لعدم امداد
قواته بالذخيره المطلوبه
اين الذخيره اللعينه انظر اليهم لدينا نقص
بنسبه 70% في الذخيره اذا اعطيتنا الكميه
العاديه منها فسيقل عدد قتلانه خمس مرات
لقد اتوا الى هنا كمتطوعين انهم يموتون
حتى تبقيا في منصيبيكما
اما على اراضي روسيا فقد اعلنت السلطات
هناك تعرض منشاه نفطيه روسيه لهجوم
بطائرات مسيره هو الثاني من نوعه في غضون
24 ساعه الهجوم تله اجتماع لمجلس الامن
القومي الروسي بحثت تحضيرات للاحتفال بعيد
النصر بحسب بيان الكرملين دون التطرق
للهجمات التي تعرضت لها روسيا في الايام
الاخيره من جهاته قال وزير الخارجيه
الروسي السرجي ان الهجوم على الكرملين عمل
عدائي لافتا الى ان بلاده سترد بما سماها
خطوات محدده وملموسه
بيان مقتضب صدر من موسكو بعد اجتماع مجلس
الامن القومي لاجتماع دوري تراسه فلاديمير
بوتين والبحث تناول التجهيزات والتحضيرات
لاحياء عيد النصر على النازيه في التاسع
من ايار مايو الحالي يعكس البيان الرسمي
سياسه موسكو في التعامل مع استراتيجياتها
العسكريه والامنيه لا تعلن عن الكثير بشكل
مباشر وتفسح المجال لتحركات ميدانيه
تستعرض من خلالها بعضا مما تخطط له
الاجتماع اتى ساعه بعد اندلاع حريق في
منشاه الى سكينفطيه غرب مدينه كريستندار
الروسيه نتيجه هجوم بمسيره اوكرانيه بحسب
الاعلام الروسي وهو الهجوم الثاني على نفس
المنشاه خلال اربع وعشرين ساعه
كثره التحليلات حول الرد الروسي المحتمل
او المتوقع لا سيما بعد محاوله استهداف
الكريم
نفذتها وخططت لها الولايات المتحده والغرب
بحسب اتهامات مسؤولينروس
من الواضح انه كان عملا عدائيا ومن الواضح
تماما ان ارهابيين كيف لم يكن بامكانهم
ارتكابه دون علم اسيادهم لن نرد بالحديث
عما اذا كان ذلك يستدعي ردا ام لا بل سنرد
بخطوات محدده وملموسه واود ان اكرر مره
اخرى ان لدينا كثيرا من الصبر
سترد روسيا اذا على الهجمات رغم توصل
اوكرانيا من مسؤوليتها عن المسيره فوق
الكرملين لكن السؤال يبقى كيف واين سيكون
الرد الروسي
خطوره هذه التساؤلات دفعت دولا عده الى
التحذير من نشوب نزاع مسلح مفتوح نزاع
يقول مسؤولون روس ان الولايات المتحده لن
تبقى بمعزل عنه
المؤشرات حتى الان ترجح ان الرد الروسي لا
يكون بالضروره مماثلا للهجمات الاوكرانيه
لكنه لن يتجاوز في الغالب سياق الردود
التقليديه
وفي مقاطعه جنوبيه اوكرانيا نقلت وكاله
تاس عن السلطات المواليه لروسيا انها
تتوقع بدء الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد خلال
ايام او حتى ساعات هذا وقد اعلن القائم
باعمال حاكم المقاطعه الموالي لروسيا عن
اجلاء السكاني ثمانيه عشره منطقه سكنيه
وبلده بعيدا عن بيوتهم بسبب تكثيف القوات
الاوكرانيه للقصف عليها وفق قوله وكتب
القائم باعمال الحاكم على تيليجرام ان
الايام الاخيره شهدت تكثيفا للقذف
الاوكراني على هذه البلدات ما دفع الى
اتخاذ قرار بنقل السكان بعيدا لضمان سلامه
الامنيين المدنيين عفوا
نشير الى العاجل الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
حيث ان الخارجيه الامريكيه تعبر للجزيره
عن قلقها زائد ادراجي محكمه الجنايات على
لائحه الارهاب بينهم صحفيون
بالجزيره يبدو انني لم اقرا الخبر بشكل
واضح تماما لان الكاميرا امامي ولا ارى
الخبر العاجل بشكل كامل
اذا ساعود واكرره مره اخرى بان متحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه نحس الحكومه المصريه
على الافراج الفوري عن المعتقلين بتهم
تتعلق بالحريات
اذا نبقى في الملف الاوكراني معنا الان من
كييف العقيد نتاليا المتحدثه باسم قيادات
قياده العمليات الجنوبيه في الجيش
الاوكراني اهلا وسهلا بك حضره العقيد
الحديث عن هجوم اوكرانيا مضاد وشيك
كيف ننتظر ان يكون هذا الهجوم
الهجمه العكسيه يجب ان لا ننتظره بل ان
نفهم انه سوف ياتي وسوف يحدث على مراحل
متعدده اولا كان علينا ان نوقف
العدو ان نجعله يستقر على حدود معينه ولقد
توقفوا على الحدود على الجانب الشمالي من
نهر النيبرو المرحله الثانيه هو تدمير
المستودعات والطرق طرق المد وتدمير قدرات
العدو
ومنعه من ان يحصل على الامدادات كل ما يصل
الى هناك يجب تدميره وهذا ما نعمل عليه
وهذا يسمى الصيد فرض السيطره بالنار ان
نسيطر على كل ما يحدث في الضفه الثانيه
حيث العدو المرحله الثالثه عندما
العدو وتدمير معنوياته
وعندما تفهم
الاراده العسكريه انه ليس هناك اي اهداف
ممكن ان يحصل عليها وينجح فيها عندها سوف
نبدا باعمالنا العسكريه الفعاله وعندها
ستكون هذه الهجمات ناجحه كان لدينا هاجمات
ناجحه في كييف في خارك اوف وفي الضفه
اليمنى من النهر واضح تماما ان موسكو
غاضبه جدا من الهجومات التي تتعرض لها
بالمسيرات
وتهدد برد
على ذلك كيف تتوقعونه
انهم
مدنيين في دوله روسيا اكثر منا بخمسه مرات
ولكن حتى لو قاموا بتعبئه جميع شعبهم
سوف يكون اكثر منا بكثير ولكننا نعمل
بعقلنا ونعمل باسلحه متطوره يقوم الشركاء
بدعمنا بها ولدينا دوافع قويه لتحرير
اراضينا نحن ندافع عن شعبنا ونحن نبني
مستقبلنا السالم في المستقبل لذلك سوف
نقوم بكل ما يقف ويعتمد علينا بالنسبه لما
يبدو تصدعا في القوات الروسيه بين فاجنر
والجيش هل تنظرون الى ذلك كمؤشر ضعف
الحمد لله نصدق الروس ولا في اي شيء حتى
في اعلاناتهم العاليه الصوت نعلم جيدا ان
هناك حرب هجينه وفي الحرب الهجينه عاده ما
يستخدم الاستفزازات الاعلاميه اليوم وفي
هذه المرحله نرى جيدا ان هناك
خلافات واضحه بين
القوات والشركات العسكريه الخاصه والقوات
الرسميه الروسيه ولكن
من المحتمل ان هذه الاعلانات من الجانب
الروسي ومن جانب رئيس قوات فاغنر قد قد
تكون هذه مجرد اعمال استفزازيه وانهم
يمثلون انهم لديهم نزاعات تجعلنا نكون اقل
حذرا او جديه وقد يكون هذا مجرد فخ لذلك
نحن نقوم بدراسه الاوضاع بشكل جيد
ونتعامل مع الاوضاع بحيث نكون على اعلى
درجات الفعاليه ولكننا لا ننظر الى
نزاعاتهم الداخليه شكرا جزيلا لعقيد
نتاليا
المتحدثه باسم قياده العمليات الجنوبيه في
الجيش الاوكراني قبل ان نذهب الى ضيفنا في
موسكو اعيد الخبر العاجل الذي قراته قبل
قليل بعد تصحيحه طبعا الخارجيه الامريكيه
تعبر للجزيره عن قلقها الادراج محكمه
مصريه لصحفيين على لائحه الارهاب من بينهم
صحفيون في الجزيره اذا هذا تصحيح للخبر
العاجل الذي قراته قبل قليل ينضم الينا
الان من موسكو الكسندر
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك
يبدو ان المعركه حول بغموت
بدت مهزوزه بالنسبه لروسيا بعد هذا الصراع
بين الجيش وفاجنر هل هذا صحيح
كلا لن اقول ان هذا شيء حقيقي هناك خلافات
معينه ونحن لا نخفي هذا لان هذا اساس
لقوتنا لا نحتاج لاخفاء اي شيء اليوم في
هناك مساحات واسعه تحت سيطره القوات
الروسيه ولكن ما لدى الاوكرانيين هو ساحه
او ميدان صغير ولدينا القدرات على التقدم
ما يقوله بريجوجن هذا شانه نحن ديمقراطيين
ولا
وليس له شان بالقوات الرسميه ما يريده
الحصول على اكثر من الذخيره على الذخيره
كبيره ولن ولن نستطيع ان نقدم له ذخيره
اكثر من باقي القوات ولقد حصل على ما يكفي
ولكن بهذا الكلام كانك تبخص ما قامت به في
حين انها يبدو انها ابلت بلاء افضل حتى من
الجيش الروسي في عديد المناطق
هي قوات هجوم وعدا لدينا قوات من الشرطه
المحليه
ولدينا قوات
القفقاز الشيشانيه وقوات الكازان وكل هذه
القوات قوات خاصه
ولدينا الكثير من القوات التي لا تعتبر
قوات نظاميه بل هي شركات خاصه وهذا ما
قامت به الولايات المتحده في افغانستان
وتماما هذا ما نقوم به نحن
نقدم الاهم المهمات الاصعب للشركات الخاصه
والكثير منهم متطوعين لذلك ليس هناك اي
شيء غريب في هذا هذا ما يقوم به باغلب
الدول في العالم بالنسبه
نائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني يقول ان
القوات الروسيه ستسعى للسيطره الكامله على
حلول التاسع من مايو
هل هذا ممكن
انه بما ان الباقي هو عباره كيلو متر واحد
واثنان واربعين كيلو متر تحت السيطره
الروسي اذا هذا شيء واقعي جدا خاصه اننا
بدانا نستخدم منظومات مدفعيه وبما ان ما
يدمر هناك هو المنازل التي اصبحت فارغه
ضخمه اي ما نسميه اصبح يشبه سطح القمر من
الدمار لذلك نحن مرتاحون باستخدام انظمه
المدافع الثقيله شكرا لك الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه الروسي الكسندر التمنوف
الان ينضم الينا من جناب العقيده الكسندر
فرافيل رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه
السويسريه واضح من كل الضيوف الروس
والاوكرانيين ان الروايات مختلفه تماما
ومتناقضه بالنسبه اليكم ما تقديركم للموقف
العسكري حاليا
نعمل نستطيع القول انه من جانب روسيا
عززت اعدادها من ناحيه الكميه هي اقوى
مكان له سابقا ولكن مع الاسف
ازادت عدد قواتها
بقوات وجنود
ضعيفي التجربه والخبره على سوبلي
قدراتهم انخفض بشكل كبير من جانب اخر
لدينا اوكرانيا التي كانت لديها بعض
الصعوبات في
اعداد الدفاعاتها اما اليوم فقد اصبح
لديها تعبئه عامه ودعم عسكري كبير من
الدول الغربيه وبالتالي في القوات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في الواقع اقوى مما
كانوا عليه اصلا قبل سنه وهذا التجرؤ على
العمق الروسي بالمسيرات هل يشكل تحول مهم
في سير المعارك
ان هذا بالتاكيد سوف يؤثر على العرض
العسكري وهو يوم مهم جدا يوم النصر ضد
المانيا النازيه
باجراء عرض عسكريه كبيره في الساحه
الحمراء في موسكو هذا بالتاكيد سيكون له
التاثير
سيحقق شعوره مختلفا عن السنوات المختلفه
من جانب اخر هل يؤثر على مجريات الحرب
فكلا لاننا زال في مجال التصعيد
هناك جراه ومحاوله القيام بالمزيد من
الامور لمحاوله الهجوم على روسيا بطرق غير
رسميه غير مباشره
طبعا موسكو تقول انها سترد على هذه
الهجمات واوكرانيا تقول بان هجومها المضاد
قريب لمن ستكون الاسبقيه بتقديرك
الاسبقيه او اليد العليا اعتقد اليوم هي
في يد الاوكرانيين بصراحه
فما فيما يتعلق بما يمكن ان تقوم به روسيا
فالامكانات امامها محدوده لانه فعلا بداوا
بحرب ضد اوكرانيا وفعلا قاموا بقصف كثيف
للعاصمه اوكرانيا وبالتالي من صعب ان
نتصور اي شيء اشياء اخرى يمكن يقوم بها
اطلقوا هجمات بالمسيرات الساعات الماضيه
ولكنها لم تكن ذات اهميه عسكريه لو قلنا
ان طرفي الصراع وصلوا او وصل الى مرحله
انهاك والى نوع من الرتابه في سير
العمليات العسكريه هل هذا دقيق
اليس هذا دقيقا
فالحسابات
من اجل النقاط الحساسه نقاط لا عوده كما
تسمى في النصف القوات الروسيه ستكون لاحقا
في هذه السنه عندما كنت تكون كثير معدات
العسكريه وهنا افكر خاصه بالطائرات
المقاتله عندما تحتاج الكثير من المراجعه
والصيانه الكبيره
وبالتالي فهناك امكانيه امكانيه حقيقيه
بان ان ان هذا هذا الشتاء القادم سنشهد ان
القوه الجويه الروسيه قدراتها لانه ببساطه
عليها الكثير من
الطائرات المقاتله جاهزه والقوات الروسيه
فعلا حاليا تعاني من مشاكل في
تعويض عن خسائرها
بمعدات العسكريه للتعويض عما فقدته من
دباب ات ومدفعيه ويكون عليهم الان يسحبوا
بمعدات عسكريه قديمه جدا في حين ان
اوكرانيا مستقره فيما يتعلق بقدراته
العسكريه
ونوعيه معداتها وقواتها التي في زياده
مستمره شكرا جزيلا لك العقيده من جنيف
[موسيقى]
منظمه الصحه العالميه الجمعه ان كوفي 19
بات تحت سيطره كافيه لكي يتم رفعه حاله
الانذار القصوى المرتبطه به وذلك بعد اكثر
من ثلاث سنوات على انتشار هذه الجائحه
التي اودت بحياه 20 مليون شخص على الاقل
فيما قوضت الاقتصاد العالمي وعمقت التفاوت
الاجتماعي لكن المدير العام للمنظمه منظمه
الصحه العالميه قال ان انهاء حاله الطوارئ
لا يعني انتهاء التهديد الذي يمثله كوفي
19 على الصحه العالميه وان احتمال حدوثه
طفرات جديده من الفيروس يظل مع ذلك قائما
بعد نحو ثلاثه اعوام ونصف حصد فيها فيروس
كورونا كوفي 19 نحو 20 مليون شخص اطلقت
منظمه الصحه العالميه نبا سعيدا اعلن
المدير العام للمنظمه تدرس ادهانو في
اعقاب اجتماع لجنه الطوارئ الخاصه
بالجائحه ان كوفيد تسعه عشر لم يعد يعتبر
حاله طوارئ صحيه عالميه بمعنى ان الفيروس
لم يعد يستدعي ابقاء مستوى التاهو بالاقصى
المعلن منذ نهايه عام 2020
حاله الطوارئ صحيه عالميه لكن ذلك لا يعني
ان الفيروس قد انتهى كتهديد الفيروس ما
زال قاتلا ويبقى خطر ظهور متغيرات جديده
تسبب طفرات جديده في الحالات والوفيات
قائما
تشير احصائيات منظمه الصحه العالميه الى
ان عدد الوفيات بسبب كوفي 19 المسجله
حديثا انخفض بنسبه 95% منذ يناير الماضي
لكن في المقابل كانت هناك سته عشر الف
حاله وفاه بسبب المرض بين نهايه مارس
ونهايه ابريل الماضيين
في العديد من الدول تلاشى الوباء وتم
تقليل الفحوصات وعمليات المراقبه الصحيه
الى الحد الادنى وهو ما تعتبره منظمه
الصحه سابقا لاوانه وتشدد المنظمه على ان
مرحله الازمه المتعلقه بالجائحه انتهت لكن
المرض نفسه لم ينتهي
اللقاحات التي ظهرت في وقت قياسي في نهايه
عام 2020 تبقى فعاله ضد اشد اشكال المرض
على الرغم من الطفرات العديده للفيروس
الاصلي
اثارت السنوات الماضيه وحسب وصف منظمه
الصحه العالميه فوضى اقتصاديه وعالميه
تجاوزت انعكاساتها السالبه الدول ذات
الاقتصادات القويه وطالت مختلفه دول
الفقيره والتي تعتمد اقتصاداتها اصلا بشكل
او باخر على الاقتصادات الكبيره
ورغم ان النبا سيسعد نظريا مختلف دول
العالم فان مختلف التحذيرات التي ظلت
تصاحب سنوات انتشار المرض والمتعلق
بالعواقب بعيده المدى التي تتجاوز انتشار
المرض نفسه
تظلماتنا
جائحه كورونا لم تكن ازمه صحيه عالميه
فحسب بل كانت ازمه انسانيه كبرى عمقت
الفجوه بين الاغنياء والفقراء
الينا من جناب ماريا
علمت الاوبئه والمسؤوله التقنيه عن مكافحه
كورونا بمنظمه الصحه العالميه اهلا وسهلا
بك سيدتي انهاء حاله الطوارئ ولكن الخطر
ما زال قائما
ماذا نفعل
الكثير من السابق
في السنه الرابعه من الجائحه بالتاكيد هذه
سنه تختلف عن بدايه
وقد انتشر هذا الفيروس قبل اكثر من سنه
وهناك انواع مختلفه ايضا لا يمكن ان تسبب
حالات حتى تصل الوفاه لكن ما غد تغيره هو
المرحله استخدام حالات المعالجه اعداد
كبيره من السكان في العالم
حصلوا على التلقيحات وايضا وهذا يعطيهم
مناعه ايضا او ربما اصابتهم السابقه
لك الرعايه الصحيه ايضا تفضل بشكل كبير
وبالتالي التاثيرات كوفي 19
الان في السنه الرابعه افضل بكثير ما كان
عن الوضع في البدايه عند منطقه هناك
علاجات او اللقاحات
لكن علينا ان نواصل الحذر واليقظه
واستخدام كل وسائل الممكنه لمن عليه
اصابات وهذا
يعني ارتداء الكمامات ولكن ايضا يعني
اجراءات كثيره مراقبه جيده حسن تهويه
وايضا هناك عاملين طبيون في المقدمه وايضا
المحافظه على المسنين
واعطائهم الجرعات التعزيزيه من اللقاح
ايضا هل يمكننا القول في ضوء كل ما سبق
بان كوفي 19 تحول الى نزله برد حاده ولكن
ليس بالضروره قاتله
لماذا السؤال مهم اعتقد انه علينا ان
نتعامل معك
بفرده مرضا وفريد من نوعه وهو لا يشبه
الزكام او
البرد في 19 يمكن ان يقتل وما زال يقتل
اشخاص الالاف كل اسبوع لدينا اكثر من سبعه
ملايين شخص
توفي وقتلوا
وخلال كل الجائحه او نعرف هذا الارقام قد
حتى يصل الى 20 مليون دينار تقديرات لان
متابعه ومعرفه كل حالات الوفاه في العالم
صعب جدا وبالتالي عليه نعتبر هذا الاعلان
بانه ان خطر الكوفيد ان هذا الفقر لا يعني
خطر انتهب انه في وضع افضل وبالتالي هذا
مرض فريد من نوعه ليس لديه موسم معين يظهر
فيه لكن الوضع حاليا يختلف تماما اذا اقل
خطوره ما كان عليه بدايه الجائحه ولكن
الجائحه لم تنتهي وهل ستستمر اللقاحات
فهناك تلقيحات
الموصى بها حسب السياسات
لاعطاء الاولويه الى الناس حسب درجه الخطر
الذي نكسر عام 60 سنه والذين
معرضين للخطر اكثر والعاملون في مجالات
الصحيه ايضا معرض المعرضون لخطر بسبب
طبيعه عملهم لذلك انهم دائما نوصي بتقديم
اللقاحات تعزيزيه معززه ايضا اما متى
يحتاجون تلك اللقاحات المعززه ولكن لابد
ان يكون هناك تعزيز اللقاحات بين فتره
واخرى ولكن ما لا نعرف نظرا لانواع
المختلفه من الفيروس ونظم حالات للتظهر
باين اين مدد يحتاج فيها الناس العد
اللقاح وبالتالي هناك توصيات مختلفه قدمت
مع استمرار هذه الجائحه شكرا لك سيده
ماريا بنك من جنيف
قال رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ان الشراكه
البريطانيه القطريه القويه ومتنوعه في عده
مجالات واضاف السونا خلال استقباله امير
دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني في
لندن ان اللقاء كان فرصه لمناقشه الشراكه
الاقتصاديه بين الدوحه ولندن من جانبه قال
امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني
ان العلاقات القطريه البريطانيه متينه
للغايه وان تبادل التجاري بين البلدين
يشهد ارتفاعا سنويا مضطردا
هذا العام سيعقد الحوار الاستراتيجي بين
بلدينا وسيناقش عده مواضيع مع رئيس
الحكومه الامن وامن المنطقه وكذلك تعزيز
شراكاتنا الاقتصاديه التبادل التجاري بين
بلدين بلغ العام المنصرم نحو 13 مليار
و500 مليون جنيه استرليني ويشهد سنويا
ارتفاعا مضطردا اذ لدينا استثمارات كثيره
هنا
وفي لندن يستعد البريطانيون لمراسم تتويج
الملك تشارلز الثالث ملكا للبلاد غدا
السبت ومن المقرر ان ينطلق الموكب الملكي
من قصر الى
كتدلائيه
للبرلمان حيث تجري مراسم التتويج وسط حضور
ممثلي وزعماء اكثر من 200 دوله اضافه الى
نخبه من ممثلي الشعب البريطاني وقد نشرت
سلطات البريطانيه الاف الضباط لتامين
مراسم التنصيب في العاصمه لندن التي تشهد
اكبر احتفال رسمي يقام في بريطانيا منذ 70
عاما
لندن تستعد لاحتضان لاحتفال بالتتويج ملك
البلاد الجديد تشارلز الثالث نحو 30 الف
ضابط يشاركون في تامين احتفال يوسف
بالتاريخي وهو تاريخي ايضا بالمعنى الامني
فالشرطه تعد واحدا من اكبر العمليات في
تاريخها ومع توسيع صلاحيتها من خلال قانون
النظام العام لتقييد المظاهرات حذرت
الشرطه من معاقبه كل من تسول له نفسه
تعكير الحدث
رساله لكل شخص يريد عرقله هذا الحدث هي
اننا لن نتسامح معه ابدا وسوف يواجهون
تحركا سريعا من قبلنا لضمان ان تمر هذه
الاحتفالات دون حوادث
لمناهدي الملكيه وامثالهم من انصار البيئه
وغيرهم يخشون استهدافهم بموجب القانون
الجديد الذي يقضي بسجن كل متظاهر يغلق
الطرق لمده قد تصل الى عام ويسمح للشرطه
بتوقيف وتفتيش كل من تشك في امره
ما سنراه هو ان كثيرا من الناس يعتقلون
لاسباب تافهه اذا طبقت الشرطه القانون
الجديد وهو تجريم الاشخاص بمجرد وقوفهم في
الشارع دقيقتين هذا امر تافه بينما
التظاهر هو حق اساسي بالنسبه الينا وفي
الذي طلب فيه من البريطانيين تاكيد ولائهم
للملك الجديد يوم التتويج تبدي منظمات
حقوق الانسان قلقها من انكماش مساحه
الحريه في البلاد
اساسي في كل ديمقراطيه سليمه ونشطه ولكن
رايناه خلال السنوات الماضيه هو ان
الحكومه سنت قوانين كثيره تسمح للشرطه
بتقييد المظاهرات اضافه الى القانون
الجديد الذي يفرض اجراءات قاسيه للغايه ما
ادى الى انكماش مساحه التظاهر وهذا امر
يثير قلقنا جميعا مع دخول القانون الجديد
حيز التنفيذي هذا الاسبوع يبقى السؤال هل
ستنجح الحكومه في اختبار تحقيق التوازن
بين الالتزام بمبادئ الديمقراطيه وضمان
امن احتفال تاريخي بحجم تتويج ملك جديد
للبلاد مينا حرب الجزيره لندن
مستمرون معكم في جوله الحصاد وهذا تذكير
بالعناوين
في ختام الاسبوع الثالث للمواجهات في
السودان
[تصفيق]
تصاعد المعارك رغم تعهدات الهدنه دوري
انفجارات قويه تزامنا مع تحليق طائرات
حربيه وسط الخرطوم وفي محيط القصر الرئاسي
ووزير الخارجيه الكيني يحذر في لقاء مع
الجزيره من تفكك السودان الى جيوب صغيره
وفي التداعيات الانسانيه للمواجهات الامم
المتحده تحذر
19 مليون شخص في السودان قد يعانون سوء
تغذيه حاده خلال الاشهر المقبله واليونيسف
تقول ان معارك السودان تحصد اطفالا باعداد
كبيره مرعبه وتكشف عن تدمير اكثر من مليون
جرعه لقاح ضد شلل الاطفال والكاميرا
الجزيره ترصد الاوضاع داخل المستشفيات
بسبب نقص الذخيره القائد ميليشيا فاجنر
يلوح بسحب قواته من بخموت موسكو تعلن بدء
هجوم الروسي في المدينه بدعم من القوات
المحموله جوا ووسط توقعات ببدء هجوما
اوكراني مضاد خلال ايام او ساعات انفجارات
تدوي في مقاطعتي زبالوجيا وخيرسون جنوب
اوكرانيا وللمره الثانيه خلال يومين هجوم
جديد بالمسيرات في العمق الروسي
بعد اكثر من ثلاث سنوات على انتشار الوباء
منظمه الصحه العالميه تعلن رفع حاله
الانذار القصوى المرتبطه بجائحه كورونا
تحذر من التراخي
وتكشف عن ارقام لوفيات بسبب الفيروس تناهز
20 مليونا هي اعلى ثلاث مرات من تقديرات
رسميه معلنه سابقا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
واشنطن تعبر عن قلقها ازاء ادراج محكمه
مصريه صحفيين على لائحه الارهاب بينهم
صحفيون بالجزيره
نبدا بالسودان والوضع الميداني هناك فقد
افاد مراسل الجزيره بوقوع اشتباكات عنيفه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في منطقه الجريف
شرق في الخرطوم بحري شرق الخرطوم واضاف
مراسلنا ان دويا في جارات قويه سمعت
تزامنا مع تحليق طائرات حربيه وسط الخرطوم
وفي محيط القصر الجمهوري دوه انفجارة
عنيفه واصوات اسلحه ثقيله استخدمت في
الاشتباكات في الاثناء قال الجيش في بيان
ان من وصفهم بالمتمردين هجموا منطقه
الخرطوم بحر العسكريه ومنطقه العاصمه
العسكريه مؤكدا انه صد هذا الهجوم
المشهد الميداني اليوم تركز بشكل اساسي في
العاصمه الخرطوم بمدنها ثلاث تحليق مكثف
للطيران الحربي مع تواصل للشبكات في محيط
القصر الجمهوري وقالت قوات الدعم السريع
انها تصدت لهجمات متكرره من الجيش الى
الشمال قليلا في الخرطوم بحري هزه
انفجارات وسط المنطقه
وتصاعدت اعمده الدخان في سماء حي الوبورات
وقال الجيش انما من وصفهم بالمتمردين
هجموا منطقه الخرطوم بحر العسكريه ومنطقه
العاصمه العسكريه مؤكدا انه تمكن من صد
هذا الهجوم
في الخرطوم بحري كذلك قال الدعم السريع ان
الجيش شن هجمات على مقاله لدعم السريع قرب
سلاح المظلات في المنطقه الغربيه من
الخرطوم بحري تحديدا منطقه حله حمد
وفي شان ميداني اخر قال الجيش السوداني ان
قوات الدعم السريع اجبرت مهندسين على
تعطيل محطات التحكم الكهرباء والمياه ماده
الى انقطاعهما عن مناطق واسعه بالبلاد
بينما نفذت قوات الدعم السري ذلك وقالت
انها تعمل على استعاده الخدمات مع الفرق
الهندسيه المختصه
هذا وقد كان وزير الخارجيه الكينيا اذ قال
في مقابله مع الجزيره ان بلاده تشعر بقلق
من احتمال تفكك السودان وتحوله الى جيوب
صغيره واضاف ان بلاده لا تريد للسودان ان
يتحول الى ساحه حرب بالوكاله
ويكون سنه
السودان نحن قلقون بشان عدد من الامور
اولا نحن قلقون من احتمال تفكك السودان لا
نريد للسودان ان يتفكك الى جيوب صغيره
فتصبح الامه السودانيه امه بلا دوله
ثانيا نحن قلقون بسبب الازمه الانسانيه في
المنطقه
ووفقا لمفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين هناك اكثر من مليون من النازحين
داخل السودان
ثالثا حيثما كانت حكومات او بلدان غير
مستقره في هذه القاره لا تمتلك نظام حكم
مستقر وفيها حروب اهليه تتحول الى ارض
خصبه للارهاب ورابعا نحن لا نريد للسودان
ان يتحول الى ساحه حرب بالوكاله
مصدر بالجيش السوداني للجزيره ان الجيش
ارسل اللواء ابو بكر الفقيري وضابطين
وسفيرا الى جده للتفاوض مع وفد من الدعم
السريع واشار المصدر الى ان قبول التفاوض
ياتي استجابه للمبادره الامريكيه السعوديه
وشدد المصدر على ان التفاوض سيكون في
القضايا العسكريه والانسانيه ولا علاقه له
باي قضايا سياسيه
ينضم الينا الان عبر الهاتف من جنوبيه
الخرطوم مراسلنا الطاهر المرضي طهر هل من
جديد
هل من جديد اسال الطاهر ان كان يسمعني
طبعا
لا جديد لان الطهر لا يسمعني باختصار شديد
ونمضي الى الخبر الذي يليه
الان اصبح جاهزا سالتك طاهر عما اذا كان
هناك من جديد
وايضا لا جديد اذا شكرا طاهر مرضي واضح
انه لا جديد ولا الطاهر معنا فتتاحيه
الانسانيه للشبكات الجاريه في السودان حذر
فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم امين العام
للامم المتحده من ان استمرار الصراع في
السودان سيؤدي الى زياده عدد من يعانون
انعدام الامن الغذائي بمليونين ونصف مليون
ليصل بذلك الى 19 مليونا خلال الاشهر
المقبله واشار حق الى الحاجه لتوفير نحو
نصف مليار دولار لدعم احتياجات طالبي
اللجوء في الدول المجاوره للسودان
يتوقع برنامج الاغذيه العالمي ارتفاع عدد
الذين يعانون من انعدام امن غذائي في
السودان ما بين مليوني شخص ومليونين ونصف
مما سيرفع العدد الى 19 مليون شخص اذا
استمر الصراع خلال الاشهر السته المقبله
وكاله اللاجئين اعلنت ان هناك حاجه الى
445 مليون دولار لدعم تدفق نحو 860 الف
فلاجئ وعائد من السودان في خمس دول متضرره
من الوضع
اعطاء المرضي معنا الان صوتا وصوره من
جنوبي الخرطوم طاهر ما الجديد
الجديد ان في هذه اللحظات هنالك هدوء في
جنوب الخرطوم لا نسمع صوت
للاشتباكات او اي نوع من اطلاق الرصاص في
هذا الاسناء هذا هدوء هدوء حدر طبعا
تعودنا ان نكون هذا الهدوء احيانا تتخلله
خروقات لهذه الهدره الهدنه المعلنه من
الطرفين بسبب ان الجيش واقوات الدعم
السريع يرون ان اي ان الهدنه لا تلغي حق
الرد في حال اي طلب اخر قام بخرق هذه
الهدنه ولذلك هم يتبادلون
الاتهامات عندما تكون هنالك اي نوع من
الاشتباكات ولكن موضوع الاوضاع الانسانيه
والنزوح من العاصمه الخرطوم وخاصه في
المناطق القريبه من مناطق الاشتباك يعني
يزال مستمر والخوف يسيطر على المواطنين في
كثير من الجوانب حتى تحدثنا عن الخدمات
وان الظروف الحياتيه اليوميه التي اصبحت
يعني فيها كثير من الصعوبات عندما نتجول
فيه الاسواق الشعبيه نلتمس ان هنالك او
نلمس ان هنالك اسعار غاليه او اسعار عاليه
فيما يقتص فيها سلعه الضروريه خاصه الخبز
وبعض
الضروريات الحياه كما ان هنالك شح في
السيوله والمواطن الان لا يتعامل مع
البنوك البنوك مغلقه بشكل كامل بالاضافه
الى تطبيقات البنكيه فيها الصعوبات كثيره
في التعامل في هذا الاطار وهي تحتاج الى
تغذيه ايضا وشراء الكهرباء كذلك ان
الكهرباء التي كانت يعني قد انقطعت عن
جنوب الخرطوم لمده خمسه ايام ومعها المياه
وان بدات تعود تدريجيا كان قد اغلقت
بظلالها على المواطنين في مثل هذه الظروف
الصعبه وخاصه في مجال الادويه التي تحتاج
الى تبريد وتحتاج الى الحفظ في درج اقل
واصحاب الصيدليات يشكون من هذا الجانب على
الرغم من ان المعضل الاكبر بالنسبه لهم ان
هنالك ليس هنالك وارد لهذه الصيدليات
باعتبار ان المصانع اغلقت او او يعني
تعرضت للسطو والنهب وايضا بعضها تعطل وان
التيار الكهربائي يؤثر على كثير من
المستودعات بالنسبه للادويه اذا نحن نتحدث
عن ازمه انسانيه مركبه سواء كانت من
الجانب الصحي وخروج عدد من المستشفيات من
الخدمه والنقص الكبير فيما يختص بالاشياء
التي يحتاج هذه يحتاجها الكوادر الصحيه
لاسعاف الجرحى
والمرضى والجانب الاخر هو الحياء المعيشيه
التي اصبحت قاسيه بسبب ارتفاع الاسعار وشح
الوقود وصعوبه الحركه من مكان الى اخر على
الرغم من ان هنالك عدد كبير من المواطنين
قد غادر الخرطوم هربا من هذه الحرب الا ان
هنالك ما يزال العدد القليل الذي ما يزال
يحاول مغادره الخرطوم لهذه الاسباب الصعبه
في في هذا الوقت تحديدا ولذلك المواطن
يتطلع بان تصل الاطراف المتحاربه الى
اتفاق ينهي هذه الحرب ويدخل الكل في حوار
يمكن ان يحقق السلام بدلا عن البندقيه
شكرا لك طاهر المرضي هذا الحوار الذي تشير
اليه والذي يصر الجيش السوداني على جعله
في قضايا انسانيه عسكريه وليست سياسيه
بالكامل نسال عن ذلك ضيفنا من بريزه
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني محمد
طرشين ما قاله الجيش بخصوص الوفد الذي ذهب
الى جده كيف تقرا ذلك
المشاهدين الكرام
في تقدير حتى الان غير واضح العالم الحديث
من وكيل وزاره الخارجيه او مندوبه البرهان
الى المنطقه يتحدث بان ما يحدث الان هو
تمرد ينبغي ان يتم معه في الاتجاه الاخر
للقوات المسلحه تتحدث عن الحديث عن وقف
دائم الاطلاق النار وهدى يتم من خلاله
فتحه مسارات انسانيه حتى يستطيع المواطن
ان يعود الى الحياه تدريجيا لكن ثم ماذا
بعد هل ستبقى الاوضاع كما هي عليها ستبقى
قوات الدعم السريعه هكذا في هدنه طويله
المدى مصير الحياه السياسيه مصيره للحياه
للمواطنين فانا في تقديري حتى الان الموقف
غير واضح لم يتبلور بالشكل الكافي كما
موقف الدعم سريع حتى الان لم يصدر بيان لم
يسمي اطراف اطرافه التي ذهبت او ستذهب الى
الى جده فهي تقديره حتى الان الطرفين
يحاولون ان يقدموا مقترحات لكن حتى الان
المقترحات لم
تحاول ان تجاوب على السؤال الجوه مستقبل
المفاوضات الاجنده التفاوضيه القضايا
المرتبطه او التي اجعلت الحرب وهي قضيه
الدمجه الدعم السريعي في الجيش السوداني
القيد الزمني مساله القياده والسيطره لمن
القائد العامله للقوات المسلحه
الايطالي في كل هذه القضايا ربما في مقبل
الان تصبح اكثر تضاحا ولكن الا تبدو هذه
القضايا الان وكانها نوع من الترف امام
وضع انساني متدهور وعسكري متفاقم وبالتالي
فاي محادثات يجب ان تركز تحديدا على هذا
البعد الانساني والعسكري قبل الخوض في اي
ملفات سياسيه
وبلاش الجانب الانساني جانب مهم جدا في ظل
شبهيه يعني اعدام كامل للخدمات وكذلك
للمواد التمويليه والامداد لكن
اقصر موضوع هل الاطراف التزمت بالهدن التي
تم
اطلاق فترات الماضيه
بكل بساطه لا كل ضرر استقل هذه الفتره من
اجل تحديد بعض الاهداف العسكريه التي يمكن
ان تشكل يعني بدايه العمليات عسكريه جديده
استطاع من خلال هذه الهدن انه يحشد عدد
كبير جدا من القوات استطاع كل طرف ان
يستعيد انفازه ويرتب خططه
وبرامج واستراتيجياته للمواجهه فانا في
تقدير الجانب الانساني لا يعني الكثيرين
والان نلاحظ ان حتى بعض التقارير تتحدث
بان الكثير من القوات الدعم السريع يحتوي
بالمستشفيات يحتمي بالاحياء يحتمي
بالمدنيين والان القوات المسلحه تتحمه
وتتهمه بانه قام بتعطيل بعض محطات المياه
والكهرباء فبالتالي انا في تقدير المساله
معقده جدا الجانب الانساني لا يعني هؤلاء
باي حال من الاحوال لاننا نعلم تماما ان
في كثير من المحطات كانوا يمكن للامور ان
تتدارك قبل ان تصل الى هذه المرحله
بالحوار وكذلك بالتفاهمات لكن الاطماع
والرغبه في الاستفراد بالحكم وكذلك
الاعتماد على على بعض المحددات وبعد
المعطيات المعقده جدا في في مسيره الصراع
جعلت هذه المعارك تشتغل وبالتالي الان كل
طرف انا في تقديره حتى استجابتهم للمبادره
السعوديه الامريكيه تاتي في اطار حتى لا
يصبح اي طرف من الاطراف معزول دوليا لا
حتى لا لا توجه له
العقوبات او اسهم العقوبات التي سهامها
التي هدد بها امس عندما منح الاذن لوزاره
الخزانه بفرض عقوبات فبالتالي هي محاوله
او مناوره من شان
الحد او تقليل المواجهه مع المجتمع الدولي
اكثر مما في النظره الى الحاجه الانسانيه
الماسه او اللغه بحاجه الى العديد من
المساعدات سواء كانت طبيه او المواد
الغذائيه او كذلك فتح مسارات والحصول على
الخدمات الاساسيه محمد طرشين من باريس
شكرا جزيلا لك
في الشان الانسانيه اوضح المسؤولون ان
السودانيين يواجهون ازمه صحيه خطيره هذه
الازمه الصحيه الخطيره خاصه تتعلق
بالمستشفيات في البلاد التي تعاني شحا في
الادويه وتراجعا كبيرا في الخدمات الصحيه
حيث يواجه السودانيون كما قلنا ازمه صحيه
خطيره بعد خروج كثير من المراكز الطبيه
والمستشفيات عن الخدمه جراء الازمه التي
تعيشها البلاد بينما تواجه المراكز الطبيه
التي لا تزال تعمل عددا من التحديات
ابرزها انقطاع الكهرباء ونفاد الادويه
وصعوبه الوصول اليها بسبب الانتهاكات محمد
الطيب ينقل لنا الوضع في مستشفى احمد قاسم
في الخرطوم بحري
نحن في قسم غسيل الكلى وحده غسيل الكلى في
مستشفى احمد قاسم عموما وضع المستشفيات
بسبب انقطاع الكهرباء مره
وعودتها في مرات يتطلبا تزود هذه
المستشفيات
بالوقود الذي يسهل لها اعاده تشغيل
الماكينات التي تقوم بتوليد الطاقه
بالنسبه لها الامر الاخر المتعلق
بالامدادات الطبيه بالنسبه للمستشفيات
والموضوع غسيل الكلى وحدات غسيل الكلى
احتياجات خاصه
يعني تختلف عن المستشفيات الاخرى
وصفات المتعلقه بالبلاد والاطفال وما الى
ذلك ونستطيع ان نتعرف على المشاكل التي
تواجه هذه الاقسام من المستشفيات وحده
غسيل الكلى مع الدكتور عثمان موسى عثمان
يعني باعتبارك مشرف
هذه الوحده ما هي المشاكل التي تواجه
المرضى الذين ياتون هنا لغسيل الكلى
وعليكم السلام واحده من المشاكل الهمه
اللي بتواجهه المرضى
يستطيعوا يصلون لهذه المركز بسبب
ارتكازات بسبب التوقف
يعني عنده مشكله ماديه واي مريض بتاع غسيل
كلى ماديا يعني وضعه ومدني اول ما بدت
الاحداث كان المخزون الموجود داخل
قسم الكلى احمد قاسم ممكن اقول لك ما
ينتهي
الليبي معدلين انا كنت بغسل 40 غسله خلال
اليوم الان بخص الستين غسله وخلاص انا على
مشارف هذا المستشفى بالتحديد يعني تواصل
الليل بالنهار هذا الطبيب الذي تحدثنا معه
قليل قبل قليل لم ينام الا ساعتين خلال
يوم امس واغلب الاطباء هنا كلهم يعملون
بجهد مضاعف هناك نقص في الكوادر ومنهم
متطوعين يعملون باستمرار في هذا المستشفى
وهم منذ اندلاعي هذه المواجهات وهذه
الازمه ما زالوا في المستشفى لم يخرجوا
منها وما زالوا يقدمون خدماتهم في اي وقت
وباي ساعه
الان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره ان السلطات
الاوكرانيه اعلنت حاله التاهب الجوي في
العاصمه
الانذار دوت في المنطقه تزامن هذا مع
اعلان نائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه تحاول السيطره على بق
بالكامل بحلول التاسع من هذا الشهر وكانت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قد اعلنت انها بدات
هجوما جديدا بدعم من القوات المحموله جوا
للسيطره على المدينه وان قوتها تواصل
التقدم في الجزء الغربي
واكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تدمير جسرا في
منطقه شاسوبايا يار تستخدمه القوات
الاوكرانيه لارسال التعزيزات الى المدينه
على محور تواصل الوحدات الهجوميه في الجزء
الغربي من مدينه باخمت مدعومه بوحدات
القوات المحموله جوا في مدينه تشاسو فيار
تم تدمير جسر حاولت القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه عبره القيام بتوريد الذخيره
ونقل الاحتياطات الى باخمت لهذا الاتجاه
بلغت الخسائر في صفوف الجيش الاوكراني 300
من العسكريين والمرتزقه
وكان رئيس مجموعه باجناريا فيجيني قد اعلن
انسحاب مقاتله من مدينه بخموت اعتبارا من
العاشر من هذا الشهر بسبب نقص الذخيره
واتهم بريوجين هيئه الاركان العامه بعدم
ارسال ما يكفي من الذخائر الى قوته بقصد
حربالها من تحقيق نصر يعجز عنه الجيش
النظامي وفق قوله
[موسيقى]
ابلغ وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان العامه
والقائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه رسميا ان
رفاق لن يتكبدوا خسائر غير مجديه وغير
مبرره في باخمت دون ذخيره لذلك في العاشر
من مايو عام 2023
سننسحب من
وفي وقت سبق نشر رئيس عبر حسابه في
تيليجرام مقطعا مصورا تظهر فيه وراءه جثث
يقول انها لافراد من قوته سقطوا في معارك
بخموت بسبب نقص الذخيره وهجم بشكل مباشر
وزير الدفاع سرقه شيغو وقائد الاركان
مستخدما سبابا مباشرا في حقهما لعدم امداد
قوته بالذخيره المطلوبه
اين الذخيره اللعينه انظر اليهم لدينا نقص
بنسبه 70% في الذخيره اذا اعطيتنا الكميه
العاديه منها فسيقل عدد قتلانه خمس مرات
لقد اتوا الى هنا كمتطوعين انهم يموتون
حتى تبقيا في منصيبيكما
وفي مقاطعه زباولوجيا
وفي وقت عفوا وفي مقاطعه زبالوجيا جنوبيه
اوكرانيا نقلت وكاله تاس عن السلطات
المواليه لروسيا انها تتوقع بدء الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد خلال ايام او حتى ساعات
هذا وقد اعلن القائم باعمال حاكم المقاطعه
الموالي لروسيا افيني بلد تشيكي عن اجلاء
سكاني ثمانيه عشره منطقه سكنيه وبلده
بعيدا عن منازلهم بسبب تكثيف القوات
الاوكرانيه للقصف عليها وفق قوله وكتب
القائم باعمال الحاكم على تيليجرام ان
الايام الاخيره شهد التكثيفا للقصف
الاوكراني على هذه البلدات ما دفع الى
اتخاذ قرار بنقل السكان بعيدا لضمان سلامه
المدنيين
اما على اراضي روسيا فقد اعلنت السلطات
الروسيه تعرض منشاه نفطيه روسيه لهجوم
بطائرات مسيره هو الثاني من نوعه في غضون
24 ساعه الهجوم تله اجتماع لمجلس الامن
القومي الروسي بحث التحضيرات للاحتفالات
بعيد النصر
بيان مقتضب صدر من موسكو بعد اجتماع مجلس
الامن القومي لاجتماع دوري تراسه فلاديمير
بوتين والبحث تناول التجهيزات والتحضيرات
لاحياء عيد النصر على النازيه في التاسع
من ايار مايو الحالي يعكس البيان الرسمي
سياسه موسكو في التعامل مع استراتيجياتها
العسكريه والامنيه لا تعلن عن الكثير بشكل
مباشر وتفسح المجال لتحركات ميدانيه
تستعرض من خلالها بعضا مما تخطط له
الاجتماع اتى ساعه بعد اندلاع حريق في
منشاه الى سكينفطيه غرب مدينه كرسنودار
الروسيه نتيجه هجوم بمسيره اوكرانيه بحسب
الاعلام الروسي وهو الهجوم الثاني على نفس
المنشاه خلال اربع وعشرين ساعه
كثره التحليلات حول الرد الروسي المحتمل
او المتوقع لا سيما بعد محاوله استهداف
الكريم بمسيره قالت موسكو ان كياف نفذتها
وخططت لها الولايات المتحده والغرب بحسب
اتهامات مسؤولين
روسنا من الواضح انه كان عملا عدائيا ومن
الواضح تماما ان ارهابيين كيف لم يكن
بامكانهم ارتكابه دون علم اسيادهم لن نرد
بالحديث عما اذا كان ذلك يستدعي ردا ام لا
بل سنرد بخطوات محدده وملموسه واود ان
اكرر مره اخرى ان لدينا كثيرا من الصبر
سترد روسيا اذا على الهجمات رغم توصل
اوكرانيا من مسؤوليتها عن المسيره فوق
الكرملين لكن السؤال يبقى كيف واين سيكون
الرد الروسي
خطوره هذه التساؤلات دفعت دولا عده الى
التحذير من نشوب نزاع مسلح مفتوح نزاع
يقول مسؤولون روس ان الولايات المتحده لن
تبقى بمعزل عنه
المؤشرات حتى الان ترجح ان الرد الروسي لا
يكون بالضروره مماثلا للهجمات الاوكرانيه
لكنه لن يتجاوز في الغالب سياق الردود
التقليديه
من واشنطن المستشار السابق في وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه ومن موسكو ديمتري
سولونيغوف المحلل السياسي والاستراتيجيه
والذي نبدا به الان
يبدو وكان الجانب الروسي بهذا الخلاف بين
الجيش وفاجنر يعيش اوقاتا صعبه ما تفسير
ذلك
في الواقع على علاقات بين وزاره الدفاع
والشركات العسكريه الخاصه هي امور قد تكون
صعبه وهذا ليس في روسيا فقط هذا في جميع
الدول ان الخلافات مستمره دائما بين
القوات النظاميه والقوات الخاصه
لا يجب ان يكون لدينا خبرات لتحسين
العلاقات بين الشركات الخاصه والقوات
النظاميه بالطبع النزاعات تكون موجوده
احيانا ولكن هناك فرص حتى نعدل العلاقات
بشكل فعال على سبيل المثال قبل سنوات
عندما كنا نستخدم قوات فاجنر في عمليات
خاصه في اوكرانيا وفي مختلف
القطاعات في العالم لذلك هناك بعض
الخلافات التي تحدث وقد يكون هذا بسبب
الروسيا
للوقوف ضد الهجمات العكسيه الاوكرانيه
هناك صعوبات بالطبع وهذا ما يتعرض له
مختلف القوات الروسيه وهنا قد يكون علاقات
خاصه
سيئه بين اداره القوه النظاميه واداره قوه
فاقنر ولكني ما كنت لي اهتم بهذا لدرجه
كبيره ولكن ليست سيئه فقط وصلت حد السباب
والشتائم رئيس الاركان ووزير الدفاع مع ان
فاجنر لها حضوه خاصه
لدى روسيا يعني الى اين يمكن ان تتطور
الامور بينهما
شخصيه عاطفيه وهو شخص ذو شخصيه خاصه جدا
وله
رد فعل على السياسات الداخليه
وهو يستخدم شهرته في الداخل ويستغل كونه
شخص قوي ولكنه يستغل هذه القوه وقوه
الشخصيه للحصول على ذخيره اضافيه اكثر من
الاخرين ويحاول لفت الانتباه لتشكيلاته
العسكريه وهذا ما يجيد فعله وعدا عن
ادارته لقوات فهو يدير ازرع اعلاميه واسعه
جدا فهو يستخدم اي سبب اعلامي لنشر
الدعايه عن قواته داخل وخارج روسيا لذلك
لا يجب ان نكون مهتمين كثيرا بكلماته هل
هو يريد ان ينجح ام يريد ان يحصل على
دعايه اعلاميه او انه يريد ان يحل بعض
المهمات العسكريه التي تحسن من مواقف
قواته كل هذا في الواقع معا هذا ما يريده
لنرى ما اذا كان السيد ماتيو في واشنطن
لديه فهم اخر للمساله
نعم لدي بالتاكيد نظره مختلفه على ما يبدو
لي ان هناك توتر كبير وشديد بين الطرفين
وايضا الخلافات تبدو جليه لان قائد
الوحدات البريط يطالب الوزاره بالمزيد من
الذخائر لقواته علنا لهذا السبب اعتقد ان
التوترات قائمه وموجوده ربما وزاد دفاع في
موسكو تتعمد حجب هذه الذخائر عنه لاسباب
سياسيه لكي لا تستطيع تحقيق مكاسب تفوق
على مكاسبها على ما يبدو لي ان
الحرب الاهليه بين الطرفين ليست متوقع
الان لكن لا يمكن استبعادها بالكليه لهذا
نرى في الوضع خطوره كبيره عليهم ولكن
الروس عاده يقولون ان هذه المشاكل يمكن ان
تحدث بين اي جيش وشركه خاصه وان شركه
الخاصه هذه ايضا لجات اليها امريكا في
العراق وفي افغانستان
هذا وضع غريب وغير اعتيادي بالنسبه
الولايات المتحده المتعقدون الاجانب
يستخدمون
للقيام باعمال شرطيه مهام شرطيه في
البلدان التي يتم احتلالها هنا هم
يستخدمونها لعمليات كبرى في الحقيقه هي
تحل محل القوات النظاميه في حاصله المتحده
مثل هذه القوات تكمل عمل القوات النظاميه
هنا قوات فاغنر تعوض وتحل محل القوات
النظاميه الاساسيه وهذا ما يؤدي الى تفاقم
التوتر بينهما في الاثناء سيد سلينيكوف
تتوالى الضربات داخل العمق الروسي عبر هذه
المسيرات
هل هذا يكشف نوع من
الهشاشه في انظمه الدفاع الروسيه
روسيا دوله واسعه جدا بمناطق مساحتها
واسعه لذلك هناك نسب بسيطه لوصول بعض
المسيرات الى الداخل الروسي وهذا واقع
لدينا حدود واسعه ومساحات واسعه جدا
وبالرغم من ان المساحات الاغلب يتم الدفاع
عنها ونقصف المسيرات هناك ولكن بعض هذه
المسيرات قد تصل للاهداف
واغلب هذه المسيرات التي تقصف الهدف تؤدي
الى اثار بسيطه لا تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
ولكن قد تصل احيانا الى مناطق تؤدي الى
دعايه اعلاميه فارغه لماذا يقومون بهذا
ربما يريدون ان
يستفزوا روسيا بان تقوم برده فعل وان تضرب
ضربات قويه في مرحله مرحله من مراح هذه
الحرب حتى
يعبئوا الدول ضد روسيا او ربما لتدمير
بنيه تحتيها روسيا في الواقع المشكله
بسيطه جدا والاضرار بسيطه ولا تؤخذ بعين
الاعتبار وليس هناك من يتضرر ولكن من
الجانب الاعلامي والحرب الاعلاميه هناك
لوحه تنشا ولها رده فعل ولا احد ينكر ان
هناك اثر لهذه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
ولم يعد احد انه لن يكون هناك اثر داخلي
بطبع هذه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه تؤدي
لتهديدات ضد روسيا وتحاول روسيا ان تنجح
في الدفاع عن المدنيين حتى لا يكون هناك
ضرر كبير والضرر فعلا اصغر من ان ينظر له
ومع ذلك سيد في واشنطن روسيا مستاءه من
هذه المسيرات خاصه بعد مسيره الكرملين
يهدد بالرد
كيف تتوقع ان يكون مثل هذا الرد
نعم هناك نقاط مهمه هنا
اولها ان مؤسسه دراسه او معها الدراسات
الحرب وهي
مركز ابحاث محترم في واشنطن يرون في هذه
العمليه عمليه ما يسمى بالرايه الزائفه اي
ان يقوم الطرف في عمليه ويلقي باللائمه
على العدو وهم يرون ان حب في عشيه
الاحتفال بذكرى الانتصار على النازيه
الروسي عاده
ينظمون عروضا عسكريه ضخمه لكن بسبب
الخسائر الكبيره والضرر الهائل الذي لحق
بالقوات المسلحه في اوكرانيا هم ربما
قاموا بهذا العمليه لتكون ذريعه لعدم
القيام بالعرض العسكري او التقليلي حجمه
اما فيما يتعلق بتبرير هذه الحرب على
اوكرانيا فهذه احدى الوسائل لذلك ثانيا لو
في هذه المرحله لا نعرف هل كان هناك هجوم
حقيقي ونجح ام فشل شكرا لكما من واشنطن
وديمتري سولونيكوف من موسكو
[موسيقى]
اعلن المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
ان كوفي 19 لم يعد يمثلوا حاله طوارئ صحيه
عالميه مضيفا ان هذا الاعلان لا يعني ان
كوفي 19 انتهى كتهديد للصحه العالميه
قائلا انه رغم ابلاغ منظمه الصحه عن نحو
سبعه ملايين حاله وفاه في العالم بسبب
كوفيد خلال ما يزيد على ثلاث سنوات فان
العدد اضعاف ذلك ويصل الى نحو 20 مليونا
على الاقل
وفي التقرير التالي نتابع ابرز محطات هذه
الجائحه
في الحادي والثلاثين من كانون الاول
ديسمبر عام 2019 لاحظت منظمه الصحه
العالميه وجود حالات مقلقه من الالتهاب
الرئوي غير مالوف في مدينه وهران الصينيه
حددت المنظمه سبب الالتهاب بفيروس جديد من
سلاله كورونا في السابع من كانون الثاني
يناير 2020
لتعلن بيجين في الثالث والعشرين من كانون
الثاني يناير تسجيل اول وفاه وفرض حجر صحي
على ووهان وفي الحادي عشر من اذار مارس
اعلنت منظمه الصحه العالميه الوباء جائحه
عالميه مع تجاوز اعداد المصابين 100,000
حول العالم وفي السابع عشر من مارس اذاب
بدات الدول الاوروبيه تعلن الاغلاق
تدريجيا قبل الانتقال الى الاغلاق التام
وبحلول الاول من نيسان ابريل اجبر قرابه
النصف البشريه على الدخول في حاله حجر
اجباري تم تطوير لقاحات في وقت قياسي
وبدات حملات التطعيم في نهايه عام 2020 في
الولايات المتحده واوروبا وخلال الربع
الثاني من عام 2021 اوقع متحور دلتا
اعدادا كبيره من الضحايا في الهند لتبدا
موجه تفشي جديده وشهد عام 2022 موجه ذعر
حول العالم بانتشار متحور اوميكرون ووصلت
الازمه الى خواتيمها في الخامس من ايار
مايو الحالي لترفع منظمه الصحه العالميه
حاله الطوارئ الصحيه
اعربت الخارجيه الامريكيه للجزيره عن
قلقها ازاء ادراج محكمه مصريه صحفيين على
لائحه الارهاب بينهم صحفيون في شبكه
الجزيره وقال متحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه للجزيره ان واشنطن قلقه بشان
استخدام محاكم مصريه لتوجيه تهمم تتعلق
بممارسه حريه التعبير داعيا للحكومه
المصريه للافراج الفوري عن المعتقلين بتهم
تتعلق بالحريات وكانت السلطات المصريه قد
اددرت اسماء عشرات الصحفيين بينهم اربعه
صحفينا من شبكه الجزيره هم عبد الرحمن
حسين وانا الزكي وعمل القزاز وسامحي مصطفى
على لائحه الارهاب وفق قرار من محكمه
مصريه
انضموا الينا من واشنطن مراسل للجزيره
احمد هزيم احمد فسر لنا اكثر
محمد هذه هذه الرد من الخارجيه الامريكيه
على طلبات الجزيره والموقف الذي جاء في
هذا الرد من اعتباري ان استخدام محاكم امن
الدوله لادراج صحفيين او لادراج اشخاص
عبروا عن ارائهم على لائحه لائحه الارهاب
المصريه هو عمل يقلق الولايات المتحده
ودعت السلطات المصريه الى الكف عن القيام
بهذه الممارسات والافراج عن من تم
اعتقالهم في السابق بسبب ارائهم او بسبب
التعبير عن ارائهم وهذا ايضا يظهر ان
الاداره الامريكيه او الخارجيه الامريكيه
بالتحديد لن لا تتبنى ولا ولا تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار الروايه المصريه التي استخدمت
لادراج هؤلاء على لائحه الارهاب وملف عالق
او ملف شائك في العلاقه
وهي علاقه تحالف بين واشنطن وبين القاهره
كتبت عليها كثير من الامور التي قوضت هذه
العلاقه مثل تجميد كثير من المساعدات
الامريكيه التي تقدم الى مصر على مدى
السنوات القليله الماضيه هذا الموقف سيشكل
ضاغطا على القاهره لكنه ايضا موقف
ليس له هذا الدلال القوي التي يمكن ان
تعكر او تؤدي الى
الى ضرر كبير في العلاقه بين واشنطن
والقاهره
المسؤوليه الامريكيين ومن تحدثنا اليهم في
وزاره الخارجيه لا يزالون يرون بان
القاهره هي الشريك استراتيجي مهم للولايات
المتحده وان ملف حقوق الانسان هو ملف
خلافي بين واشنطن وبين وبين السلطات
المصريه هناك تتصد تضغط الولايات المتحده
بين الاخرى على القاهره في هذا الملف لكن
تبقي تعاونها في الملفات الاخرى حاضرا رغم
هذه هذه هذا الملف الذي يقوض العلاقه بين
الطرفين محمد شكرا لك احمد هزيم من واشنطن
الى لبنان الان حيث اطلقت السلطات وحمله
مسحا لتعداد وتسجيل اللاجئين السوريين
هناك واتخذت اجراءات اداريه وامنيه بحق
هؤلاء اللاجئين خاصه غير النظاميين وشرعت
القوى الامنيه في ترحيل نحو 600 لاجئ الى
سوريا الاثناء حذرت منظمات امميه واخرى
حقوقيه من مخاطر اعاده اللاجئين الى سوريا
بشكل قصري
يفتقدون الامانه في المخيمات هو حال تلك
الفئه من اللاجئين السوريين القلقين من
احتمال ترحيلهم
اكثرهم يخشى الحديث للاعلام درعا للمخاطر
اما من يجرؤ على الكلام فيؤكد على حقه
بالعوده الامنه لا بالترحيل القصري
هذه قيمه
نحن لا تحصدون على السكن بهذه الخيمه نحن
لو في هلا الارضيه الخاصه نقدر نامن على
حالنا وعلى اولادنا نحن ما بنبقى ولا سنه
اجراءات السلطات اللبنانيه استهدفت ايضا
الجمعيات التي تؤمن لهم المساعدات فهذا
المركز الطبي الذي يوفر خدمات للاجئين
والمواطنين في بلده عرسال مهدد بالاغلاق
نتيجه قرار تنظيمي من السلطات
مرحله استثنائيه عندما يتنافى الوجود
السوري في لبنان طبعا هذه المراكز كلها
فنتمنى نتمنى من المسؤولين ان يوقفوا الى
جانب هذا المواطن الى جانب هذه البلده الى
جانب لبنان وبينما تطالب الامم المتحده
بان تكون عوده اللاجئين طوعيه لا قصريه
ترى السلطات اللبنانيه انه يجب ترحيل من
لا يلتزم بالقوانين وتطالب الامم المتحده
بان تشطب باللوائحها اللاجئ الذي يزور
بلاده دوريا يشعر اللاجئون السوريون
بالقلق من ترحيل من لا يملكون اوراق
النظاميه منهم وذلك بعد تاكيد السلطات
عزمها اعاده من دخل منهم الى لبنان خلصتا
ويتزامن ذلك مع ما يوصف بخطاب التحريض ضد
اللاجئين السوريين وتاتي هذه الاجراءات مع
تصاعد ما يوصف بخطاب التحريض ضد اللاجئين
في ظل تفاقم الاوضاع الاقتصاديه في لبنان
اذ ترى السلطات ان وجود
الحق خسائر بالاقتصاد واثر على المجتمعات
المضيفه وهو ما تشكك به منظمات امميه صار
في موسميا كل سنه سنتين حاله تاجيج ضد
اللاجئين بالخطاب الرسمي تليها حملات يا
اما ترحيل يا اما تنظيم عوده طوعيه
الحكومه اللبنانيه جددت دعوتها المجتمع
الدولي الى تحمل مسؤولياته تجاه اللاجئين
وايجاد حل لازمتهم في ظل انفتاح العربي
على دمشق النزوح السوري صقله كبير على
لبنان
ونستطيع ان نقول تعبنا
قلنا انت لما بتحمل لك حق تعبت تعبنا ولكن
لسنا عنصريين وبدات السلطات اللبنانيه
التحضير لحمله جديده لما تصفها بالعودات
الطوعيه للاجئين السوريين وهو ما تحذر من
مخاطره جمعيات حقوقيه ترى ان شرط العوده
الامنه الى سوريا غير متوفر وان حياه
العائدين قد تكون مهدده ايهاب العقد
الجزيره عرسال شرق لبنان
[موسيقى]
نتوقف في هذه الفقره عند انظمه الصواريخ
هاي مارس المريكيه وذلك بعد ان كشف
مسؤولون بالفانتاغون عن تشويش روسي اثر
على فاعليه المنظومه الصاروخيه نبدا من
يونيو حزيران عام 2022 حيث زودت الولايات
المتحده القوات الاوكرانيه براجمات صواريخ
من نوع هاي مارس وصواريخ اخرى موجهه
بالاقمار الصناعيه استخدمت تلك الصواريخ
لضربه مستودعات الذخيره الروسيه
والامدادات اللوجستيه ومراكز قياده القوات
الروسيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
مصنف منظومه هيمرس على انها راجمه صواريخ
دقيقه التوجيه تحمل الواحده منها سته
صواريخ من عيار 2007 ملم بمدى يقدر بنحو
80 كيلومترا لكن الولايات المتحده لم تزود
اوكرانيا بنظام هاي مارس للصواريخ
الباليستيه الذي يبلغ مداها 300 كم لانها
قادره على ضرب مواقع داخل روسيا وهذا ما
لا تريده وشد وقد كانت صحيفه قد نقلت عن
ماسونينا امريكيين القول ان الفانتاجوان
اجرى تعديلات سريه على منظومه هاي مارس
بحيث لا يمكنها اطلاق صواريخ بعيده المدى
بما في ذلك منظومه الصواريخ التكتيكيه
التي زود بها اوكرانيا والتي يبلغ مداها
نحو
لكن ماذا عن اهميه صواريخ هاي مارس هذه في
جبهات القتال في اوكرانيا هل حققت تغيرا
حاسما على الارض وماذا عن تفاصيل هذا
التشويش الروسي نبدا من التشويش نبدا من
التشويش فقد نقلت شبكه
عن مسكونا بوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه القول
ان انظمه صواريخ هايمان اصبحت اقل فاعليه
بشكل متزايد باوكرانيا بالاشهر الاخيره
وذلك بسبب التشويش الروسي المكثف
اضاف مسؤوله فانتاغون ان التشويش الروسي
اجبر المسؤولين الامريكيين والاوكرانيين
على ايجاد طرق لتعديل برنامج هاي مارس
لمواجهه جهود التشويش الروسيه المتطوره
ولكن ماذا عن التاثير الميداني احدى ابرز
الهجمات التي استخدمت فيها هذه الصواريخ
تعود الى مطلع العام الحالي في دنيا حيث
قتل فيها اكثر من 60 جنديا روسيا والى
جانب دقه التوجيه يشير خبراء عسكريون الى
ان منظومه هاي مارس تتميز بدائره استهداف
واسعا نسبيا تعطي القوات الاوكرانيه اذا
طول خصوصا عند خطوط التماس لكن الخبراء مع
ذلك يشيرون ايضا الى صعوبات تحول دون
ارسال عدد كاف من هي مارس الى اوكرانيا من
بينها توفر قطع الغيار والحاجه لتدريب عدد
كبير من الاوكرانيين لتشغيلها
ينضم الينا الان من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي قضيه
الصواريخ هذه تبدو معقده حضره الدواء ولكن
لنبدا على الاقل من هذا التشويش هل هل هذا
التشويس يعتبر انجاز روسي
نعم يعتبر انجاز لانه حد من قدرات هذه
الصواريخ الصواريخ يعني في كل حرب يظهر
اسلحه مفاجئه
ويستطيع الخصم ان يقلل من قدراتها
وامكاناتها باتخاذ بعض الاجراءات سواء
السلبيه او الايجابيه الان اذا ذهبنا الى
بدايه استخدامها فيشار حزيران الماضي قدمت
الشيء الكثير سواء في قصف منظومه الامداد
مستودعات الوقود مستودعات الذخيره دعم
القوات المهاجمه ولا ننسى العمليه
العسكريه السريعه في خارقه وبالتالي الذي
مهد لهذه العمليه وساهم في انجاحها كانت
صواريخ هاي مارس وبالتالي بسبب هذا
التاثير كان لزاما على روسيا الجيش الروسي
ان يتخذ اجراءات منها الايجابي ومنها
السلبي يسمى الدفاع السلبي والدفاع
الايجابي اما ما هو الدفاع السلبي او
الاجراء السلبي
تكيف معها باعاده توزيع ونشر
المستودعات سواء الوقود او الذخيره وقلل
من حجم نقاط التكديس وبعثرها على جغرافيا
اكثر فبالتالي اصبحت الان بحاجه الى
الجانب الاوكراني الى معلومات استخباريه
دقيقه هذه الصواريخ تعمل عبر نظام الجي بي
اس يعني لا يمكن ان تكون فاعله الا اذا
قدم لها معلومات واحداثيات دقيقه جدا تدخل
على الحاسوب ومن ثم يتم استخدامها وهنا
تظهر دقه العامل الاخر وما يسمى بالدفاع
الايجابي وهو هذه الصواريخ صواريخ ذكيه
تعمل عبر الاقمار الصناعيه على ترددات
معينه فبالتالي يصبح هناك ما يطلق عليه
الجيمنج او التشويش الذي
يشوش على حزمه التردد
طبعا هناك اجراءات واجراءات مضاده ندخل في
نظام القفز الالكتروني الى ما شابه ذلك
ولكن هناك اعتراف حقيقي من قبل الجيش
الروسي بالجيش الاوكراني بان فاعليه ليست
كما كانت في بدايه المعركه وهذا امر متوقع
تسليط الضوء على صواريخ هاي مارس كشف ما
سمي بتعديلات سريه على انظمتها بمعنى لا
تستطيع ان تذهب اكثر من مدى معين هل تعتقد
بان
القوات الاوكرانيه وقعت في نوع من التضليل
في هذا المجال
لا يا سيدي هي يعني هي اولا
هذه الراجمه اذا استخدم فيها الصاروخ
التقليدي مدى 80 كيلو متر 227 ملم قطره
هذا مصمم اصلا وهذا اقصى مدى يمكن ان يصله
ولكنها مزوده بحاضنه مستقله يستخدم فيها
الصاروخ الذي يصل مداه الى 300 كيلو متر
وهذا لم يتم تزويد الجانب الاوكراني به
وتم اجراء التعديل بحيث لا يمكن حتى لو
وجد صاروخ بديل يمكن
مواصفاته فنيه
تتوافق مع متطلبات هذه الراجمه لا يمكن
استخدامه اي بمعنى اخر تم تعطيل جزء من
قدراتها من قبل امريكا قبل اجسادها هذا
التشويش الروسي هل
يقلل نوعا ما من هيبه هذا النوع من
الصواريخ
اذا جاز التعبير
لا اعتقد ذلك لانه هذا الامر حصل في يعني
اذا تطرقنا الى الحروف في المنطقه اسمها
العربيه في عام 56 كان عامل المفاجاه سلاح
سلاح الجو لم يستفد الجيش المصري من ذلك
ففي 67 اعيدت نفس الماسه وكان الرقم الصعب
سلاح الجو في عام 73
ظهر صاروخ التاو ولم نستطيع ان نستوعب هذه
الصدمه فبالتالي هو كان لاعبا رئيسيا في
عزمها لكن بالمقابل تمكن الجيش السوري
والجيش المصري من مفاجاه اسرائيل بمنظومه
صواريخ سام فلم تستطع ان تتجنب تاثيرها
خلال فتره الحرب ولكن فيما بعد استطاعت
ذلك اذا دعني اقول في كل حرب يكون هناك
سلاح جديد يحدث نوع من الصدمه ولكن اذا
طال امد الحرب هنا يتم البحث عن ايجاد
اليه سواء كما قلت لك بالدفاع السلبي او
الدفاع الايجابي
للحد من قدرات هذا السلاح شكرا لك من
اعمالنا لواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي
[موسيقى]
بينما ننهي الحصاد هذه الليله نتذكر محنه
اكثر من بلد افريقي في هذه اللحظات تابعنا
بعض اللقطات مثلا في جمهوريه الكونغو
الديمقراطيه خلفت الفيضانات قرابه 150
قتيلا واعدادا كبيره من المفقودين في
اقليم جنوب كيفو بشرق البلاد الامطار جرفت
مئات البيوت اتت على حقول حتى ان المياه
فاجات باعه وزبائنهم في الاسواق هذا ما
يقوله مسؤول في المنطقه المتضرره في
رواندا ايضا اسفرت فيضانات وانزلقات
للتربه نجمت عن امطار موسميه غزيره عن
مسرح ما لا يقل عن 100
شخصا في شمال البلاد وغربها وجنوبها وذلك
في احدى اسوا الكوارث التي شهدتها في
العوامل الاخيره ويشهد شرق افريقيا
بانتظام فيضانات خلال مواسم الامطار
ويتوقع خبراء المناخ ان تزداد شدتها
وتيرتها بسبب التبدل المناخ الامل كل
الامل ان يتقلص حجم الخسائر خصوصا بين
البشر جراء هذه المحنه والتغيرات المناخيه
شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]